[Music]  this surreal fortress was built on the  remains of a medieval castle by one very  curious man  [Music]  is located in the northern alpines of  italy  construction began in 1850 and was  commissioned by counter caesar mate who  was a self-taught inventor and quite the  eccentric  his intention was for this castle to be  the home of his medical revolution a  concept based on using the energy of  plants to heal physical ailments  his eclectic sensibilities are reflected  in the labyrinth design of randomly  connected rooms  mate passed away at 87 years old but he  didn't go far he's buried in the chapel  which is decorated elaborately as a  replication of cordoba's mosquito in  spain  for the last 20 years of his life he  never left the castle and after his  death it was all but abandoned until  2005 when an independent group took over  and restored the site opening it back up  for the public to explore this very  unusual residence  [Music]  you